foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to create a database in
SQL but before we begin I'd like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you're a tech
deak in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply run now without further Ado let's
get started with our agenda for today's
session that is how to create a database
in SQL so first let's have a quick look
on the syntax we use to create a
database so first we have a create
keyword which will explain the SQL
Server that we are trying to create a
new element which can be a database or a
table next we have the keyword database
which clarifies the sequel that we are
trying to create a new database the next
one is not mandatory if not exist just
we are trying to make sure that the
database that we are going to create is
not already existing so if you use this
if not exist then SQL will tell you in
case if there is an existing database on
the same database name then it will not
allow you to create a duplicated
database and followed by that we have
the database name which can be anything
so I've just created as database name
here now that we are clear with the
syntax let's get back to the IDE that is
MySQL to execute a command to create a
new database so now we are on the SQL
workbench now let's quickly try to log
in
there you go now you can see some
existing databases on the left hand side
of the workbench sysr system is the
default one so I already created test
and trial let's try to create a new one
right away so the create keyword
database
keyword and then if not exists
so here you can see I'm trying to
capitalize the keywords so that it's
easier to understand what is the code
and what is the user defined names right
so create a database if not Xs and
click done
DB
that's our code let's try to execute
this and there you go so here you can
see in the action output create database
if not exists simply non-db has been
executed successfully now we can run a
new code which says show databases
this should show us the newly created
database which is simply learn DB which
is right over here so that's how you
create a new database in SQL and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on how to create a new database
in SQL if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in this
session or if you require the resources
like PPT or the demo code we used do let
us know in the comment section below and
RTM of X Plus will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here